bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang got will here
with me thanks so much for doing this
man
hey bob hope you had a good week man
it's great to be back
absolutely let's jump right into it this
week was uh pretty bullish it started
off and then all of a sudden elon
decided to uh
start tweeting and things got kind of
crazy what exactly happened
yeah so you know the past couple weeks
um in the newsletter and on
these podcasts we've been kind of
describing a bullish
setup right now this consolidation that
we've been in now
for jesus it's been two or three months
and uh we've just
kind of been waiting for a confirmation
in either direction
um and then elon around 6 p.m on on
wednesday
uh he decided to come out and tweet
whatever he did about
bitcoin's environmental impact and that
had a
big impact on the price in short term
right after he decided to tweet that we
had 200 million dollars of long
liquidations
within 10 minutes so just looking at you
know just
what was driving the price that was what
caused that huge initial dump that we
saw
um but it was very interesting to see
before he actually had tweeted that
there were i think it was 19
500 roughly uh bitcoins that were moved
on to exchanges in the hours before
which is very suspicious to me because
then after the dump
you saw this huge outflow of coins from
exchanges so
to me at least it seems like somebody
had some kind of information
about what was going to happen yeah and
what's really fascinating to me
really is here um when you see that much
liquidation
uh it's such a short period of time it
almost feels like people
felt like the market had bottomed they
then were uh putting this leverage on
and were ready to kind of return back
upwards but instead there was kind of
this
you know external event that wasn't uh
perceived in any of the on-shade metrics
and that's really what drove all those
liquidations and kind of caught people
not uh you know unexpectedly
yeah absolutely and i think this this
kind of uh
goes to the whole thing about bitcoin is
talking about not to use leverage and
just to buy spot because
you never know when an event like this
is going to happen and
as you just said i think a lot of the
market was expecting a
break out of this consolidation that
we've been in for a while and they were
starting to add in some leverage back on
and so when this happened a lot of those
leveraged traders just
got absolutely wrecked yeah and so talk
a little bit
uh more about the bitcoin that got moved
on to the exchange
uh what did you see there do we know who
that was and then you said there was
some bitcoin moved off of the exchanges
afterwards
yeah so a few hours before the dump um
there were 19 000
i misquoted the number earlier it's 19
259
bitcoins that were moved on to exchanges
and then
afterwards so this is just running a
moving average anyone can see this in
the letter and then i think we're going
to have these charts up on the video as
well
but um you saw i just ran a moving
average over the net transfer volume and
there's a huge increase before
and then after there's a decrease in
transfer from
exchanges actually people are starting
to move coins off of exchanges following
the event
um but it's hard to know exactly which
you know which entity it was but um i
find that very suspect because it would
be
quite a coincidence i completely agree
uh it also looks like about 650 million
dollars worth of tether got printed
what's going on there yeah so
after we had the big dump first of all
we saw one of the biggest outflows from
exchanges in
since february it was only trumped by
one that we saw
towards the beginning of april so in
addition otc
outflows also spiked so there are
definitely some people that stepped in
and scooped up some cheap coins and then
as you just mentioned
there's a lot of tether printed in the
24 hours following
about 460 million dollars of tether and
then also we saw just in general
650 million dollars roughly of tether
moved on to exchanges
in the 24 hours following which
obviously
um isn't signaling bitcoin buy
specifically like
they could be buying other all coins as
well but um a fair portion of that it's
fair to say is going to bitcoin
and it also doesn't mean that they're
buying um immediately
they could be you know just moving that
capital onto exchanges and then they're
slowly going to wean into
a position but that capital is there on
the exchanges waiting to be deployed for
sure
yeah and it one other thing i wanted to
touch on was this metric sopr
so this is something that we've we've
discussed in previous
newsletters and pods so sopr just
basically measures like the net
profit loss of the market on any given
day
and during this event i ran a six hour
moving average
in a 24 24-hour moving average over this
metric
and on both of those time frames we have
the biggest drop in
sopr um of the entire bull market
so you know in in the bull market when
we have these uh crazy uh
price runs not a lot of people are
willing to sell at a loss
and so when you see a huge portion of
the market um
or i shouldn't say a huge portion but a
majority portion of the marsh of the
market
selling at a loss that's usually a sign
of a bottom
and this metric has timed each bottom
that we've had
throughout the entire bull run so if we
aren't at a bottom here and
at time we're recording we're about 50
300
if that 46k that really nasty wick we
saw from the from the long liquidations
if that wasn't the bottom then
we're very close to it but based off of
this
this sopr metric which like i said has
timed most of the bottoms
we should be very close to a bottom here
and
and also we bounced off two major moving
averages that kind of
serve as uh bull market support so
there's the 128 day moving average
um which has never been uh there's never
been a daily close below that
moving average during a bull market we
actually bounced within
a hundred dollars off of that moving
average and then we also bounced off the
21 week moving average
which isn't to say if we have one daily
close under one of these that the bull
market is over and it's time to pack it
up and go home but
if we had multiple daily closes below
that i would i would start to get a
little concerned but
we did bounce pretty strongly off of
both of those moving averages
which when when you look at you know
previous cycles after we've had those
corrections
to come back and retest those moving
averages we've had some pretty crazy
gains in the coming weeks and months
following that
remind us what the funding rate meant
kind of metric is and then what happened
on the funding rates
yeah so the funding rate is another
metric that you can kind of use to time
the bottom i think the you know the
funding rates and the
sopr are two of my favorite metrics to
use to kind of
get a rough estimate about where we are
and you know
if we're close to the bottom of in these
corrections
so the funding rate is used on different
exchange platforms
overseas where they have these perpetual
swap contracts
so the way you can just think of this is
that it's a futures contract
that doesn't have any expiration um and
it's pegged to the bitcoin price
and so the way it's pegged um is they
they have something called an oracle
which takes like a weighted average from
different exchanges
coinbase binance kraken etc
and they're all weighted based off of
how the amount of uh
volume that they have on their exchanges
and then there's an average price
which is which is what the oracle um
gives these uh
these trading exchanges um for example
like bit max right and
um or ftx is another popular one and so
the the contracts the perpetual swap
contracts are pegged to that oracle
price through funding rates
so when the majority of the market wants
to go long
the funding rate goes up which means
that
the longs are actually paying shorts to
incentivize people to take the other
side of the trade and therefore
peg that contract to the oracle price so
you know when the market gets super
bullish
it's a the funding rates can be a good
tool to kind of gauge the sentiment of
traders because
you start to see that the traders are
paying a high premium to
sustain those those long positions um
and and when funding rates go negative
it's showing the opposite the majority
of the market
is looking to go short and therefore
their funding
longs to take the other side of the
trade there and during the
during the event after elon decided to
tweet that
we saw the funding rates go negative and
then what was interesting though is we
saw this very sharp bounce back in
funding rates
um we had a decline for i'm looking at
it now about seven or eight hours
and then out of nowhere we just shot
right back up which i find that very
interesting i don't really know what to
make of that but
in the previous corrections that we've
had in this in this bull market we've
seen
um funding rates just kind of creep back
up slowly it was very interesting to see
them come
come right back but those funding rates
going negative in combination with
uh the sopr which was um had gone below
the one
uh threshold which we've we've talked
about before um
that on multiple time frames those
things are giving me a signal that we're
very close to the bottom if we haven't
reached one
got it and when you start to think about
um kind of the leverage that was in the
system it feels like a lot of that got
flushed out here
yeah absolutely so you know when you
just flat out or looking at
the futures open interest we had a huge
wipeout during this event about
1.8 billion dollars of futures open
interest in total
which is a good thing because um you
know in the short term
price then doesn't have as much weight
to uh speculative traders and
and it's more weighted by the organic
buying or spot buying
that's taking place rather than just
speculators uh jumping in
and uh the price being driven up through
that way so
i think that's a good thing to see this
leverage get flushed out and
the greed kind of moving out of the
markets in general
yeah one of the things that's so
fascinating in your analysis uh
is you're able to look at the various
wallets and how much bitcoin they have
in them and kind of what those are doing
uh maybe talk us through what you would
expect to happen in a bull market
between kind of small walls medium size
and large and then what actually is
happening right now
yeah that's a great question so you know
there's for the for the very small
wallets
um i don't know like .001 btc
to one btc um you're seeing those those
very small cohorts have been
accumulating steadily throughout all
bitcoins existence and they continue to
do so throughout this bull market
when you look at you know some of the
higher uh threat
of the cohorts you see different things
so for example like the
10 btc to 100 btc has been trending down
um the 100 btc to 1000 btc has actually
been trending up
um especially in the last couple months
which i think is something to keep a
close eye on because that
that threshold is kind of the the high
net worth individuals in my opinion
and then you have the thousand btc uh up
which is what what glass node likes to
just label as whales
and that's actually peaked out um and i
think coindesk put an article
out about this um and saying that it was
kind of a negative thing i just see it
as
kind of neutral because you started to
see these whales trim out of their
positions
um midway through each cycle and in 2017
they actually
the the peak of whales that were coming
on the network
was around 675 dollars which of course
was
you know very very far from the top
and it's just something that you start
to see them begin to take profits about
midway through the cycle
so that's not anything abnormal but it's
something i'm keeping an eye on just the
behavior of these different
uh entities because obviously um you
know the larger
the larger entities tend to be
institutions or
uh high net worth individuals and you
can get some signal based off of what
they're doing
um but i think that that 100 btc
to 1000 btc cohort is an interesting one
to keep an eye on
because although we just mentioned the
whales are selling off
that cohort is actually offsetting the
um
the decrease in supply coming from the
larger cohort
so it they're offsetting it by i think
it's 86 000.
um so what that illustrates to me is
either you know there's just more buying
from these high net worth individuals
or also maybe you know some of these the
larger cohorts let's say they have
um you know 10 000 btc in an address
right and bitcoin's gone up so much and
they want to say okay
i'm gonna de-risk um my holdings so i'm
gonna spread
um you know 1 000 into 10 different
wallets
and and that would move them into the
other threshold into that lower cohort
and then also if someone's right on the
verge like let's say they have a
thousand
two btc or a thousand five btc and they
sell off a couple or they throw a couple
on to binance to
you know mess around with some altcoins
you'll see
those those uh specific entities move
into the lower
lower cohorts so it's a combination of
things but i think you need to look at
all the different cohorts to
get the full picture rather than just
looking at one specific one and drawing
to any conclusions
yeah what are miners doing uh this week
yeah it's a great question so you know
we've been talking about how miners have
been accumulating and throughout the dip
they have just continued to do just so
there's two
major metrics that i look at for this
one is the minor net position
change which is basically runs this 30
day
trailing um average on on the net
position change of what miners are doing
are they
selling or accumulating and they
continue to accumulate
they've been this metric's actually been
in the green for over a month now
which is very interesting because uh
towards the you know
middle to end of last year from about
august to late october
we saw a very similar signature in this
metric that they were just kind of
accumulating during the consolidation
before the next price run up
so in my opinion that illustrates that
they're just waiting for higher prices
there's another metric last night has
called minor unspent supply
and it's just basically measuring and
rather than running an average it's just
literally looking at the raw
balance of minor wallets um during the
dip we actually saw an uptick in that
um so miners miners seem like they're
they're
still super bullish on the asset and
they're expecting higher prices
got it and then long-term holders feel
like another big metric that we should
be paying attention to
yeah so glass note has a metric called
uh it just looks at the total supply
based off of um
you know what long-term holders are
doing and that kind of bottomed out we
did see them sell off
after all-time highs at the end of last
year but it seems to have bottomed out
around march
april and that's actually starting to
move up again which is interesting you
start to see them reaccumulating at
these levels
i guess to them that these seem like
more attractive levels to start adding
on some more to their stack
perhaps once again because they're
expecting higher prices
also there's very similar to the miner
net position change glass node has a
metric called
long-term net position change which is
the same thing it's running an average
over the trailing 30-day difference of
the
of the uh the behavior of this cohort
the long-term holders
and that's been in the green for over a
month as well so that's it's
illustrating a very similar picture one
metric i wanted to touch on was nvt
um so nvt was the original on-chain
metric
that willy woo came up with um he likes
to analogize it to kind of a p e ratio
of the bitcoin network as kind of a way
to
find a fair valuation of bitcoin based
off the the fundamental investor
activity
and it's just a very simple ratio of
market cap to the on-chain transactional
volume
so nvt when it when it's going up it
means that
the the market cap is growing
faster than the underlying investor
activity or on-chain transactional
volume
and when it's going down it means that
the
on-chain transactional volume is
outpacing the growth of market cap so
it's a very simple ratio
but that ratio has been trending down
since january um so to me that's that's
another indicator of what we've been
talking about recently about how we're
just in this
consolidation um and two other things
you can look at um
realize cap right so that's a good way
to track capital inflows to the market
because um realize cap is is
similar to market cap but it's based off
of when coins last move
and we've seen um this huge increase the
year-to-date we're over 300 billion
dollars added to realize cap
which is showing that there's capital
coming into the network and as that new
capital comes in it's setting this new
price floor for bitcoin
um and then if you take realize cap and
then divide it by supply you get
realized price
and uh realized price actually crossed
the 2017
all-time high market price of 20 000
this week
which is in my opinion a really good
sign that you're seeing
capital come in and flow and flow in at
these higher price levels and kind of
set a new floor for us and then
on a very similar note if you just look
at the on-chain transactional volume
itself
we continue to just build this huge zone
up uh
near you know this these 40 to 60
thousand dollar price levels
especially in the in that you know 54 to
call it uh 57 58 thousand dollar range
there's a lot of
support there but even as far as um
just coming down to about 45 000 to 60
000 there's a lot of distribution in
that area
which is showing to me that we're not at
the top because when you get to these
these tops
there's increasingly uh parabolic moves
until finally we have this big blow off
top
it's not like we consolidate for um you
know granted
this is my first bull run but i'm just
looking at the data but i'm sure anybody
that's been in a bull run before can
vouch for this that
there you don't just consolidate
sideways for two three months and then
just fall off cliff
you have these these huge price run-ups
and then when you get to the
when you get up higher people stop
selling people start to get
greedy and people stop taking profits
and you don't have a lot of distribution
a lot of on-chain volume distribution at
those top levels
but we're seeing the complete opposite
right now we're just seeing this huge
zone of support which is just another
way
to to illustrate that we're just in this
big consolidation
i think you know the price action that
we saw on wednesday
certainly put a damper on how how soon
that we would break out
but uh it's it's nothing that changes
any of the on-chain structure
i've been getting a lot of uh people
asking if you know
that price dump changed anything and in
my opinion it changes nothing it's just
a short term price move but
when you're just inaudible fundamental
investor behavior on chain
uh nothing that we've been talking about
has changed at all
yeah it just feels like short term
everyone freaks out long term we're
still good to go bull market in check
and uh consolidate for a little bit and
then we'll see what happens in the
future
yeah and it's a really good thing in my
opinion i think the volatility is very
necessary because
you see all these short-term speculators
or people that haven't done their full
research on
a what bitcoin is or how the price
behaves anybody that's been in bitcoin
knows we have these crazy price swings
i think in 2017 we had like seven or
eight corrections over 30
on the way up and that's just part of
the way bitcoin behaves
and you know when you have these big
price drawdowns um
new um you know the stronger hands step
in and scoop those coins up from those
weak hands that that panicked and
and sold off so uh i think it the
volatility is very necessary for
moving coins to strong hands which then
then allows price to move up from there
yeah where can people find you on the
internet or
or subscribe to your email yeah man so
right now uh
for anybody listening uh pop and i
started the newsletter
on my sub stack it's btc by wc3
dot substack.com and then also we're
putting out a friday letter on pomp's
which i'm sure most people on pomp's
podcast are subscribed to but
that's kind of a weekly recap and then
of course we're doing these uh saturday
podcasts to kind of run over everything
from the week but the ones i'm putting
out on my channel are
kind of you know just a weekend recap if
anything's changed
and then i'm doing as well a wednesday
recap of just anything you know
touching based in the middle of the week
if if needed if there's if nothing has
really changed in the on-chain structure
i'm probably not going to put out that
wednesday letter but if we see something
happen like um
this week i put one out because we had
some interesting uh developments in the
launching structure so
i'll be putting out two to three of
those a week between
my newsletter and pomps you can find me
on twitter at
wclementi and then three eyes at the end
because i am the third in my family but
uh yeah other than that i'm
pomp and i are gonna keep pumping these
out and i'm glad you guys are finding
some value in these i really enjoy doing
them
doing a fantastic job keep it up my
friend and we'll do this podcast again
on a saturday
yes sir appreciate you